When the lights went up in theaters showing
"The Batman," there was still one more riddle
left for moviegoers to solve — just what
exactly happens if you go to the website the
Riddler uses in the film?
Watch to the end of the video to find out.
Oh, and it should go without saying, but major
spoilers ahead.
Now, if you've already seen "The Batman,"
directed by Matt Reeves, then you know that
there's a lot to unpack.
Following Robert Pattinson as the Caped Crusader,
the movie is set in a dark Gotham brought
into chaos by a killer called the Riddler,
played by Paul Dano.
Thanks to the heroic efforts of Batman, Catwoman,
and Lieutenant Jim Gordon, the Riddler's plan
is stopped before he can completely destroy
the city and its citizens.
But even though the good guys win in the end,
"The Batman" still hints at there possibly
being more to come with Riddler in the future.
Throughout the film, as our heroes attempt
to track down the Riddler, the villain leaves
puzzles for Batman to solve.
One riddle in particular leads him to a website
with the URL of rataalada.com.
This connects him with the Riddler live through
a simple, coded chat, through which Bruce
digs for any answers he can get out of the
criminal.
While the website is a secret tool for Riddler
in "The Batman," Warner Bros. decided to actually
create the website in real life.
So what happens when you head there?
"What the hell are you supposed to be?"
Keeping in line with the website's function
in "The Batman," rataalada.com brings you
into a conversation with a chatbot made to
mimic the Riddler character from the movie.
He offers you the chance to play a game and
solve three riddles, and if you get them all
correct, you will unlock "the truth."
Fair warning though: the solutions to these
riddles aren't easy, and we aren't all experts
at riddles like Batman appears to be.
Even so, in "The Batman," Bruce has some help
from Oswald Cobblepot a.k.a.
the Penguin and Lieutenant Gordon, but in
this case, you're on your own.
Adding to the feeling that you're talking
to the real Riddler, a man who's an expert
at codes and technology, the website is well
aware of how much time you take between guesses,
whether or not you go to another tab or window
to try and look up the answers, or even if
you close the window entirely and return later
to try again.
If you think you're smart enough to conquer
these three riddles and claim the prize, you
can head to the website and see what you unlock.
"Who are you, under there?"
Before the movie's release, the site featured
riddles that would unlock promotional material,
like police sketches of Batman from the Gotham
City Police Department.
But now that the movie has debuted, the reward
for providing the right answers has changed.
"How am I a part of this?"
"Oh you're really not as smart as I thought
you were."
If you manage to get all three riddles correct
— and there are only three riddles in total
— then you can unlock a secret image of
the Wayne family from before Bruce's parents'
death.
The photo shows Thomas Wayne, Martha Wayne,
and a young Bruce — played by Luke Roberts,
Stella Stocker, and Oscar Novak, respectively
— relaxing on the floor in the lavishly
appointed living room of Wayne Manor.
In the film, the Riddler's personal connection
to the Wayne family plays a major part in
his plan.
So, it makes sense that one of the secrets
the Riddler reveals is connected to this part
of Bruce's past.
The caption underneath the photo describes
the image as having been taken during Thomas
Wayne's mayoral campaign, while also mentioning
the Renewal Corporation, the latter of which
has plenty of significance in the plot of
"The Batman."
Meanwhile, the image file itself is named
"no me rompas," which translates from Spanish
into "do not break me."
Meanwhile, if you visit the site again after
you've solved the riddles and received the
first image, you'll also get another image
of a message in the Riddler's code.
Can you solve it?
There could even be more on the site to discover
over the coming days and weeks, which might
either lead to additional material related
to "The Batman," or something that hints at
the Riddler's future…
"Please do not lie.
What is the price for your blind eye?"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "The Batman"
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.